daddy's not choppy and macho's us
disgusting Capaldi I'm a
singer-songwriter from Scotland and I'm
also a very plenty little kettle as you
can tell with my glasses today I'll be
talking you through some of our favorite
Scottish slang words and I will be doing
it in the form of ASMR because I want to
see how many pair felt something there I
can make Climax by whispering in the
real job a job'
a job' as a my house is caked in because
I thought anyway he pray after I thought
I'd your pee-pee Iwilei
really well if someone looks pili Wally
they look sick
they might kilo foot it died bank back
the Scottish language is one of the most
romantic and there's a day of languages
in the world
something bad but being like I want I
can't
drank tonight because buttocks tight and
I need to take money to palliate Europe
back kiyotaka
yes mr things I've watched online miss
him dearly
I'm up the cheering
Bobby Bobby your mum's favorite part of
the human anatomy your papi is your
piece I don't think in English your
testicles
pictures like that was what he's that
was one of these bless is a fairly
famous scholars we have a sallow Carol a
mum comes and banging teleca's who
doesn't know her to flush the toilet
after the father she she replies that
was near me and was relevant and what
he's discussed and what they should have
said to the mum was a Xavier scooby-doo
she and the toilet mentally for sure off
you know this is one of our favorites
cause what's daddy's daddy's best rests
if you're a man of a certain weight
which I am studies Hagen Balkan soap
organ just essentially means disgusting
they are Balkan in the past have went up
to a lady
that's it gotta buy you a drink and this
is kept it your pocket
he'll go for a job and a job II could be
particularly gross and now's a bargain
job
[Music]
taps are perhaps if you dump this
college when the weather's like do any
degrees or something that's perhaps
laughs whether they take a top there's
nothing to do with plumbing bashed best
best is just when you're Betty Betty
Betty drunk you can be so pêche that you
pass yourself but you wouldn't job
yourself because you were pest that
doesn't work like a button a job' and
not shows us because I was patched does
work banished so thanks very much for
watching my ears Emma video I want to be
taken seriously as a musician by my
[Music]